a little
okay so I'll be talking about the
program the quantum wave in computing
which is in spring 2020 and it's
organized by andrew child's ignacio
Ciroc my choise irani and Tomas fitting
in upcoming years we expect to have
quantum devices with upwards of 50 noisy
qubits so these practical developments
bring with them major theoretical
challenges and the program will focus on
these challenges so these challenges can
be roughly split into two categories the
first is algorithmic so in this setting
the question is what can we do with
these limited near-term quantum devices
so what useful computations are possible
with these devices in the longer term
once we reach our eventual goal of
full-scale fault-tolerant quantum
computing the question is what are the
applications of these computers so we
expect that the key application should
be simulation of physical systems but
there are many other applications which
we will explore in the program now the
other major theoretical challenge has to
do with testing these computers so once
we have larger quantum computers we will
no longer be able to classically
simulate these devices with
supercomputers due to the exponential
complexity of quantum states currently
we're still underneath this threshold so
in practice people are using techniques
such as benchmarking or testing for
quantum mnestheus supremacy but
eventually we will have to deal with
this issue of testing larger quantum
computers so in this talk I'm just going
to focus on this issue of testing since
at its core this issue of testing is a
complexity theoretic question with deep
ties to classical cryptography
now if I want to phrase it as a
complexity theoretic question here's how
to see it our goal is to classically
verify some quantum behavior so we have
a classical computer which we refer to
as a verifier and a quantum computer
which we refer to as a proofer and the
verifier is going to interact with the
prover and the goal of this interaction
is to verify some quantum behavior so
there are many things we could hope to
verify for example we could want to
verify that the machine is quantum so we
could want to achieve quantum supremacy
or we could want to verify the output of
a general quantum computation or
something
like homomorphic encryption or certified
randomness generation but all of these
questions are just about the power of
interactive proofs so how much power can
this week classical verifier have over a
quantum proof now this imbalance between
the verifier and the prover can be
addressed by classical cryptography and
here's how so the quantum proveer is
quite powerful but he's not all-powerful
we can take advantage of the fact that
the quantum machine is still efficient
so he's polynomial time bounded and we
can assume that there are certain
problems that even an efficient quantum
computer cannot solve in other words I'm
assuming quantum secure cryptography
which is classical cryptography that an
efficient quantum computer cannot break
now so far what I've said is that the
verifier is much weaker than the prover
and in order to level the playing field
all I've done is I've upper bounded the
power of the quantum theory but the
verifier still remains much weaker than
the prover so in order to handle this we
can give the verifier
access to a trapdoor and for example
with the one-way function access to the
trapdoor would allow the verifier to
invert the one-way function while the
quantum provers still could not invert
the function so in this way by giving
the verifier access to something that
the quantum prover does not have we can
level the playing field between a
classical verifier and a quantum group
and this structure of using cryptography
to allow the classical verifier power
over a quantum approver has been used in
a recent line of works to achieve
various cryptographic tasks including
classical verification of quantum
computation homomorphic encryption
certified randomness generation and
quantum supremacy all of these results
rely on the assumption that the learning
with errors problem is quantum secure so
these results introduce an exciting new
connection between classical
cryptography and quantum computing more
specifically between lattice problems
and quantum computing and it seems like
this connection would be best explored
by collaboration between those who work
on lattices and those in quantum
computing and that's why spring 2020
seems like an ideal time to explore
these questions given the concurrent
lattice program and as an example of let
me just give you a few examples of the
types of questions we can explore now in
all of the current results we heavily
relied on the structure of learning with
eros to build these protocols and it was
quite surprising that learning with
errors did have enough structure to
allow them to allow that problem to be
so useful with quantum computers and one
question is whether there are other
structural properties of lattice
problems which we haven't explored yet
which could be useful in other types of
quantum cryptographic tests and another
question has to do with standardization
of lattice problems so we expect that in
upcoming years RSA will eventually be
phased out to be replaced by lattice
problems and as part of that
standardization process we need to
figure out what structural properties of
lattice problems make them both
efficient and keep them secure against
quantum computers and that type of
question seems like it would really best
be handled by people working on quantum
algorithms and lattices so we can figure
out more about the structure of these
problems and I'll end there
great questions what are the reasons we
really believe that the structural
learning with errors is pointless
what are the reasons behind the belief
that the structure of learning with
errors of secure learning with errors
basically there's been a lot of effort
put into breaking these problems and we
haven't been able to so we have quantum
algorithms which work with certain types
of structure like with factoring and
this type of structure is not present in
learning with errors because we've got
no we can't get our current quantum
algorithms successes in quantum
algorithms like factoring in discrete
log etcetera these are billions but once
you get to sufficiently all the improves
then you seem to be quite hard and and
and you know there's these are
and
is there any work on sort of verifying
complex the operation of a complex
quantum computer with a simpler
complement computer like freaks it you
know the the fact that good verification
with a classical machine is obviously
great and you and that's a nice result
by the way but I guess my question you
know we if we had modest power on
machines would it make it would it
change the problem like in terms of the
complexity assumptions we knew there was
a lot of work on that before this
because we didn't know how to handle it
with a classical verifier and there what
was shown that if the verifier has the
capability of just receiving a single
qubit and performing measurements it's
enough to verify information
theoretically without provocation
yeah yeah so the question is yes it's
possible without any computational
assumptions there are some issues with
fault tolerance so it's not clear
whether it would be practically useful
[Applause]